salut à tous jusqu'à envergure en vidéo
mais ce sera évidemment aujourd'hui au
programme ou petite analyse moudre au
top 8 de la draft pour des analyses il
faut des analystes
donc c'est une fille envergure vous le
voyez notre romain leroy il est de
retour
comment vas-tu romain je voulais voir
comment alsacien mais je crois pas donc
ça va 130 matches joués cette saison 2 2
finale fort et une saison beaucoup trop
long sur leurs impôts dgi je rappelle
pour l' île dupas salut les copains je
suis désolé 1 je suis ravi ne soyez pas
surpris s'il ya des gens qui vient de se
demander ce que font les gens qui font
wimbledon à côté ils comprennent pas
trop ce qui se passe on va pas parler
tennis 1 aujourd'hui mais mais on va
parler justement de la draf alors
d'habitude vidéo montre verte de
redescendre d'un échange avec nous tu
rigoles tu rigoles je pense que toni
kukoc serait flatté d'avoir pris les
devants de romain le rock à billy a
minima avant de commencer juste un petit
petit cadeau petites annonces
on peut on peut le dire que vous serez
tous les deux le soir de la draft
on peut on peut sincèrement que tu poses
la question en tout cas oui la draft
raccordables en live sur ville gratuite
au soir on sera à l'écrou main
techniquement aussi s'il peut se libérer
et j'espère avec quelques options comme
d'hab' pour refaire la team qui avait ça
l'an dernier donc voilà on va revivre
ensemble cette belle soirée avec romain
elle est magnifique voilà une très bonne
nouvelle qu'on vous annonce une nouvelle
fois honoré de l'invitation chez
envergure et notre expertise sur le
plateau via via ce beau gosse de romain
alors j'ai 29 juillet ouais si ça plante
naviguer drap sur bin sport nous on sera
sèche et la first in occupent maintenant
qu'on a fait les présentations jeu de
rôle graf
on va faire comme si on était le soir de
la draft romain et rennie vont être les
décideurs des franchises donc romain
d'occident pratique xiaoting rémy sera
plus coté general manager donc celui
vraiment valide la décision à la fin moi
je serai modestement adam silver 3000 un
pic avant d'y aller
roman est ce que tu peux juste en deux
fois mieux dire que fait le directeur de
strauss
quelle analyse ils apportent quelles
infos de la direction du scouting chez
chu qui va prendre qui va prendre des
décisions avec notre honte aux fiches
qui va centraliser les infos un petit
peu et qui va soit faire le bon choix
soit faire la bêtise
pour faire simple je suis qui est payé
pour pour faire soit le bon choix soit
la bêtise en gros dans certaines
franchises dont celle dont on parlait de
talent ordre commence à enregistrer
c'est plutôt des bêtises dans d'autres
ça peut être parfois des bonnes
décisions donc voilà c'est un petit peu
le le rôle après d'une franchise à
l'autre vous avez soit directeur du
scouting sur les six temps gm qui a été
directement dédié à sa une organisation
à l'autre ça peut varier un petit peu
mais de la chine a dit et là on ne
citera évidemment pas là rémy toi tu as
le gm donc on va demander un peu plus
d'avoir un oeil sur l'ensemble des
composantes du club l'ex coach donné ce
contexte le jauger ce qu'un choix de rap
c'est quand même un mélange entre autres
évaluer un talent et le placer dans un
bon contexte afin de maximiser premier
choix de draft romance détroit
run this town donc réuni être 3 ou
weezer et tu as le premier choix et
c'est partit alors par le nord de
détroit est ce que est ce qu'on prend
tout simplement la première chose qu'on
prend deux meilleurs talents disponibles
ou est-ce qu'on se pose des question
d'alchimie celle et c'est l'éternelle
question déjà ses pistons c'est
bizarrement pour une équipe qui a un
premier pic pas l'équipe qui a le plus
de besoins remplir j'ai l'impression
c'est une équipe qui a des pièces qui
sont en train de se mettre en place qui
part de loin en termes de construction
mais quand même il ya des trucs pour
cette équipe chez les pistons il ya
jeremy graines en simili franczak player
pour l'instant il ya des jeunes joueurs
il ya sadig biya qu'il ya nice qu'on va
vouloir sur une saison pleine donc voilà
il ya des choses intéressantes
moi j'ai l'impression quand je regarde
l'effectif là dedans qui manque déjà de
scoring pure et j'ai l'impression qu'on
manque de celui qui devra à court ou
moyen terme est le franchise player de
cette équipe
il faudrait trouver un talent avec un
premier pic de draft qui dans deux trois
cinq ans max pourrait emmener cette
franchise vers les play-offs et plus
haut oui parce que tu as des cimes il y
prenait 16 heures donc ça manque donc le
alpha dog romain nikki qui est candidat
selon toi sur le premier sur premier
choix cette année je pense qu'il ya
quand même un consensus global on peut
pas forcément aller ailleurs que sur
quelques lignes âme parce que sur ce
qu'il peut apporter notamment sur le
scoring la capacité de venir fin de
chasse d'ailleurs ça me parait ça me
paraît clair sens de ce corps et ça doit
gagner un petit peu en en création mais
c'est une bière et dit même s'il même si
athlétiquement il ya des petites
questions
malgré tout c'est un malheur de jeu à
deux mètres et est leader de son équipe
et et qui a dès qu'il ya des choses à
faire valoir
difficilement faire autrement que sur
quelques dixièmes je pense à me la draft
c'est que dans un mois ça fait un moment
qu'on reconnaît à peine une gamme valide
la vallée bleue fois j'ai évidemment pas
votre expertise en terme de scouting des
mecs mais sur canal
environnement il ya consensus ça a l'air
d'être le fort talent est assez loin de
ce que je comprends de cette classe donc
que c'est très difficile de passer à
côté pour une équipe comme détroit qui a
plein de talent toute façon donc oui je
valide évidemment très bien coté sajoo
avec la balle mais il sait jouer aussi
sans ballon certains vont peut-être voir
ça comme une mauvaise nouvelle pour
qu'ils n'aillent pas vraiment cette
année à venir en irak casser le favori
pour le parti que vous avez choisi
deuxième but qui est le ponot
astronautes là il ya un peu plus de
questions sans doute avez vous tué à
raphaël stone 10 m des houston rockets
et c'est partit alors parlons d'épargné
roquettes besoin pour mon dieu mon dieu
mon dieu alors là c'est pas le même cas
de figure que détroit parce que qu'on le
coup tu as besoin de quasiment mais
vraiment de tout alors ça me fait si on
prend ce qu'il ya dans l'équipe
aujourd'hui parce qu'on sait qu'elle a
été complètement explosé cette équipe
avec le départ de james harden l'an
dernier et encore john wall qui est là
dedans moi ça me fait mal au coeur parce
que j'adore ce mec
mais john wells et c'est de la chair à
canon dans le sens où dans l'immédiat
pour eux c'est la matière
ils n'ont pas construire cette franchise
autour de john wayne je vois pas ça
arrivait dans ce qui reste une fois que
on se libère de john hall d'une façon ou
d'une autre je vois deux joueurs majeurs
ou que tu auras du mal à traiter ou tu
as peut-être regarder c'est eric gordon
et christiane woods qui sont des pièces
intéressantes dans des registres
différents
et du coup alors s'il faut cibler un mec
parce qu'il faut bien cibler un mec sur
ce deuxième pic mois j'identifie deux
besoins principaux à houston de la
défense dans la raquette du poste du
post 4 5 défensifs ce que n'est pas
christiane woods clairement et du shoot
extérieur c'est une équipe ça fait
bizarre de dire ça pour houston mais qui
a besoin de shoot extérieur
donc voilà l'un des deux besoin que
j'aimerais remplir avec ce deuxième pic
peut-être avant tout du talent
pardon j'aurais dû commencer par là mais
ça va sans dire que koenig gamme sera
plus dispo donc si j'ai le deuxième plus
gros talents bruts jeu peut piquer
quasiment sur tous les postes créés jeu
j'en aurai besoin de façon kevin porter
dit kevin porter junior toujours la
barre un peu mal d'années
robin
comme profil avec déjà le deuxième au
talent et ensuite peut-être le voilà le
fil des rencontres
deuxième plus gros talent et
intelligence en défense et pour moi de
ce que j'ai vu de ce que j'ai regardé ce
matin un petit peu evans meublaient peut
faire sens c'est peut-être pas forcément
dans la peinture calcul de besoin mais
son profil un petit peu un petit peu
longiligne est une vraie agilité même si
l'on savait pas forcément encore assez
l'épaule sur certaines choses et se
désunit un petit peu c'est intelligent
en défense ses 16 points 8 rebonds avec
avec youssef isse de m 13 et de 26
d'envergure je pense qu'elles les
arguments à faire valoir
cergy si on part sur le ratio talent
brut potentialités et éventuellement
capacité à se projeter rapidement je
pense que je pense que me blesse un peu
ça peut faire sens sur le profil un
petit peu post 5 ans j très mobile ça
peut être intéressant dans dans une
équipe de houston ont je cherche encore
un petit peu donc voilà cc c'est pas des
collants sur le deuxième selon evans
mobley donc pour pour le deuxième choix
rémy c'est valider ça fait classe à
combler des besoins
on va parler de tout à l'heure j'ai ce
besoin là qui est comblée j'ai un talent
à priori important sur ce deuxième
piquet j'aurais perdu tous les étages
toute façon que je valide le choix des
vannes bouclez vos choix numéro trois
dans la peau de de kobe altman cette
fois puisqu'on parle direction les cav's
donc la quête qu'une gamme est parti je
rappelle evans mobile elle est partie en
deuxième fille les caps rémy qu'est ce
que pour toi godoy doit rechercher cette
franchise est ce qu'on a toujours besoin
d'un bon super star qui se porte alors
c'est une bonne question là pour le coup
à cleveland
autant les deux premiers choix déjà
précieux qui sont faciles à effectuer au
temps actuel en il faut se poser des
questions il va falloir faire des choix
justement déjà dans l'effectif actuel
quand tu regardes qui a qu'est ce qu'on
fait de kevin love est ce qu'il ya une
décision qui est prise à un moment et
source décident de se séparer de kevin
love est ce qu'on arrive à ses parents
kevin leroux passe c'est important le
deuxième choix qui va être important
c'est c'est ce qu'on croit vraiment
toujours
duo d'arrières la foux colis de sexton
tarrius garlande moi la seule valeur
sûre vraiment sûr dans ce roster qui me
plaît c'est isaac okoro drafté l'année
dernière qui a été bon clairement si
pour x ou y raison l'une des deux
premières franchises vont pas sur evans
mobile et ça peut me plaire parce que
parce que parce qu'il va falloir
redoubler ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
mais si comme tu l'as dit evans mobile
et plus dispo je me demande s'il serait
pas temps de faire sauter le duo sexton
garlande sans doute en gardant sexton
j'imagine
et encore je m'aime pas sûr et pourquoi
pas prendre prendre prendre à notre un
autre combo un autre arrière sabre noir
ça pour ça pour être l effectivement
c'est vrai que c'est une option n'a pas
forcément pensé mais toutes façons
appartiendra dans la période des rumeurs
si tu veux prendre si tu veux rester sur
ce sur ce principe de duos d'arrières tu
as la solution de jal est le seul qui
ait pas à quel paquet pas inintéressante
parce que joueur leader dans une rage
une équipe qui est quand même reconnu
pour son jeu globalement à gonzaga fort
sur les changements de rythmes cycle ou
encore t'es en avant promenant ce qu'il
peut faire et perd encore un petit peu
la balle il ya des aspects of offensive
jeudi à améliorer mais dans l'idée je
pense que ça peut être site avec 6
tonnes c'est un joueur qui peut jouer
sur les deux postes arrières bon pas
forcément de gros gros shooter à trois
points mais des choses à des choses
intéressante quand même est une équipe
qui a été loin sur le sur le tournant
final donc quelqu'un qui sait gagner
aussi et je pense que nos outils comme
clivante qui se reconstruit
avoir un joueur qui est habitué à gagner
un petit peu et qui sait comment gagner
au niveau universitaire c'est pas
inintéressant de de mettre ça dans la
dans la balance l'us lui que diane
greene donkey alors on explique
rapidement mais en gros le deuxième
panier de talent au niveau des joueurs
il ya peut-être une gamme qui est au
dessus et ensuite c'est un groupe de
trois mots glade ringtone syndicats
s'étaient vus par la part des
observateurs lâchera plus
je suis je suis plus sereine parce que
gris il ya quand même
un côté vision un petit peu tunnel à
certains moments qui associait sexton ça
peut faire beaucoup ça peut faire un peu
duo d'arrières un peu kamikaze préféré
quelqu'un capable de ne plus jouer sur
les deux positions et d'avoir un jet à
la pointe depuis bastia est plus élevé
parce que le terme serait dur mais
quelqu'un qui puisse apporter un peu
plus de 2,2 balance dans le sur la ligne
arrière
c'est mon choix je peux dire une
connerie mais voilà après on va rémy la
fonction aussi c est ce que si on veut
absolument evans mobley qui apporterait
de la sérénité à l'intérieur
nouvellement 2009 est-ce qu'on peut près
dé aussi d'une position quoi aller
chercher le vélo boulot à cleveland a
beaucoup de cette marge de manoeuve là
après la question de la marge de
manoeuvre il est toujours que c'est
compensé par les valeurs de contrat le
l'atout numéro 1 qui vendent est ce que
c'est un atout d'ailleurs où un poids
c'est kevin love aujourd'hui s'attaquent
eux kevin love ya un moment ou un autre
si tu le mets dans un package il va
falloir tenir quelque chose en retour
tu as le troisième qui claquent et vine
love est ce que ça peut pas obtenir son
deuxième victime et du salaire contre
balancer j'en sais rien après si tu
décides de te séparer de darius garlande
ou de colis de sexton ça reste des
gamins qui ont de la valeur
aujourd'hui c'est des gamins qui ont un
potentiel je pense que tu as moyen de
package et pour monter de dinde un pic
dans la draft pour aller chercher votre
beau pays
après ce que houston à faire aller
chercher d'une aide surnuméraire en
arrière sauf si la question
voilà ces échanges pour une pige en tout
cas donc est-ce que tu valides de notre
fameuse barrière dont d'ailleurs un peu
plus gestionnaire pour ça va dans
l'hypothèse où on fait sauter cette
espèce de deux bases arrières chelou
laos extrême rigueur de samba ok alors
partons là dessus et on va il est tout
petit sur le pwa numéro 4 tu vas être
dans la peau de bobby webster puisque
c'est toronto qui a fait le bon coup de
la loterie quand même content en choix
numéro 4 alors toronto ça une situation
très particulière quand même pas par
rapport à une équipe qui normalement
quand on piquant 4000 on a on a plus de
trous à combler de savoie oui dont tu as
raison c'est ce que tu as dit c'est un
coup de chance incroyable de piquer en
quatre pour pour pour toronto et tant
mieux pour eux il en faut de temps en
temps aussi ils sortent on sort du coup
les raptors d'une année étrange c'est
cette année un peu un peu bizarre de ne
sait pas trop si c'était une année de
transition pas de transition ça jouer à
tampa c'était il ya eu le trade apporter
de calorie on la trendline et où enfin
tout ça c'est un peu bizarre cette année
à toronto
moi il me semble qu'il faut commencer à
préparer à préparer l'après kyle lowry
il sera free agent l'âge on sait pas ce
qui va faire personne ne sait ce que va
faire kyle lowry il va intéresser du
monde
je pense qu'il faut préparer l'après
kyle lowry est allé chercher un meneur
ou un combo pierre plutôt un mineur
parce que des arrières j'ai l'impression
que tu en as déjà un meneur pur dans
cette draft
ça me fait du bien je pense meneur
vraiment combler un trou qui tu as
peut-être descend en marchant talent je
te vois venir je te vois venir avec kim
johnsson nomba djahnine ce que je
pourrais faire sens là aussi par rapport
par rapport au profil qui auraient sinon
derrière si on part sur 2 sur dur du
meneur pur on accueille johnson mais qui
est peut-être plus limité en plus limité
en talents dont moi je suis je souhaite
recentrer berceau pas forcément ouais
c'est c'est un combo puis moi je suis
pas je suis pas forcément un un grande
fan il faudrait que je creuse encore un
petit peu
sinon il ya la solution la solution
sharif cooper qui peut qui peut
également dans un rôle de meneur scoreur
apporter quelque chose
c'est encore très limitée dans deux tirs
à trois sapeurs cannes ballons par match
parce que ça part un peu dans tous les
sens mais bon est-ce que c'est presque
que c'est pas en terme de talent brut le
simple le plus simple est la solution la
plus rapide ascension nous seuls qui
n'est pas forcément disponibles et que
les petits as johnson me rassure pas
forcément il ya le côté choisir du
talent aussi
on a entendu déjà des rumeurs de trade
eu ce tir calmes que les warriors
voudrait aller chercher donc il ya des
gars des combinaisons sont possibles et
ce que si est-ce qu'il est envisageable
quand même rémy de john fust meilleurs
talents disponibles et enfile devoir
bien sûr parce que cette cette franchise
mode quand je te dis que l'on sait pas
trop ce que c'était cette année de
transition ou pas c'est que c'est le
genre de situation que c'est les
franchises se pose des questions et
marshall opportunité c'est à dire que là
il n'y a pas de chemin évident pour que
toronto redevienne un contender pour un
titre nba dans les cinq ans moi j'en
vois pas en tout cas donc il faut sauter
sur les opportunités
si t'as pas
si t'as rien qui se propose à tous cet
été comme tu disais une opportunité de
trading et wario tu t'y faire sauter le
groupe et se séparer de sa came ça peut
s'étudier clairement si t'as pas ça et
battu draft oui le talon le plus fort ça
peut être ça peut être la solution la
plus simple aussi dans ce cas là on a du
bien aussi ce que tu barnes est pas mal
moi ce qui me les deux choses qui me
gêne l ex-coach barnes et sont un jeu
lancé qui est catastrophique
ce qui doit être à 62% ou quelque chose
comme ça on est pas sur des valeurs
crise de la neige ou la recherche de
leur chère à rémy mais on est quand même
pas voilà et derrière il ya surtout il
ya pas de tir extérieur et c'est
peut-être un peu une limite c'est à dire
que ça va être un vrai profil
intéressant mais ya pas de y'a pas tirs
extérieurs derrière j'aime beaucoup ce
côté barnes mais ça me paraît encore un
petit peu il est libéré dit sur le corps
mais il ya encore des choses à
développer que donc avoir de l'amour
je garde je garde garde à l'oeil la la
rumeur je m'éloigne wright à toronto si
tu veux je suis plus une rumeur qu'autre
chose mais mais j'aimerais que yi charia
trouve un spot donc si ça peut être à
toronto qui le suit depuis longtemps
tant mieux y a pas d'infos non non c'est
juste une rumeur c'est juste que je les
ai vu passer ces derniers grands et j'en
ai parlé avec lui
déjà il ya l'intérêt de plusieurs
équipes nba sur lui et c'est de ce côté
là c'est justement on va y a des infos
qui s'appelait bonbons koné qui les
décideurs à binche
écoute moi si je veux si je veux mon
après si je veux mon après calories
compare pas sur l'idée de faire exploser
l'équipe puisque beau jason spezza il
peut pas faire la faire mais on l'a bien
pris en 3 à brindas free party balfe on
sort on va jouer mais à mon directeur du
scouting moi je veux un vrai bonheur
dans ce cas dans ce cas là on part sur
jive cooper avec le risque et le risque
sur le côté un petit peu encore à
comment dire à apollinaire en terme de
jeu mais sur sur les meneurs pur c'est
ce qui reste de disques wave ski voilà
pour moi il apporte plus de garanties
que johnson ne serait ce que sur le
scoring
j'adore le risque sharif hooper en
classe j'adore ça aucune ya rien de
rationnel dans ce qu'on fait c'est pas
avant s'enflamme sais pas mais moi
j'aime beaucoup charles cooper et pour
avoir regardé les matchs au lycée il
shootait bien mieux à o'byrne n'a joué
que 11 matches
donc c'est largement s'est largement
quelque chose d'envisageable pour moi en
nous avons une soit 5 et le choix vite
donc on va faire le simple au format
faire dans l'ordre une équipe qui aime
la draft et des gens qu'on dénombre à
john hammond le gm d'orlando a imposé
une amende
qu'est-ce qu'on a du côté d'orlando mais
comme on doit forcément gardé quoi alors
toronto c'est quand même une équipe qui
est au stage 0 de sa construction mais
alors vraiment je suis dur mais c'est la
réalité du truc quand ils ont tout fait
péter à la tête d'eads line dernière
c'est c'est clairement le but c'est que
d'ailleurs ils ont même pas de coach
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est que tu
vraiment tu reprends toutes les
fondations là tu as deux pics élevés le
5d lui tu l'as dis donc ça j'ai
l'impression que ça t'enlève étrangement
ça peut paraître antinomique mais sa
tournée de la pression c'est à dire que
tu peux tenter des choses tu peux te
permettre de tenter
tu as un pic au talent un pique un peu
surprise d'un truc comme ça moi cette
équipe là alors oui tu peux regarder ce
qu'il ya dans l'effectif
tu peux regarder tu te retrouves avec
des gars yaris des tons poste de meneur
tu sais pas trop parce que marquer le
full ce toujours un peu pété parce que
parce que cole antony tu ta pas de
certitudes à tous les niveaux de façon
pas besoin de quelque chose
moi je pense qu'il faut que tu draft au
talon
et au potentiel choisir les joueurs qui
dans deux trois ou cinq ans max seront
les plus forts possibles
c'est une directive r ça va donner du
côté du directeur du sillon draft si on
draft aux talents je suis j'ai j'aurais
juré garde à ce que j'ai lu tableau
devant moi si on grafteaux de sion sion
dans jal et du mur il peut que faire
sens parce qu'il ya un potentiel it et
kunming a pesé glisser là aussi
effectivement et scotty barnes et là je
vois trois jours ci à deux pics je vois
trois joueurs pour de piquant fait
potentiellement j'aime bien books night
mais c'est là c'est là c'est pas évident
c'est vraiment une question d'une
question de roster et de chantier green
green pour moi s'il encore dispo à ce
moment là ce qui peut arriver ça ce
n'est que sur le cinquième choix ça
paraisse apparaît totalement logique
c'est un petit peu en difficulté face au
contact mais ses efforts dans le ragot
du un contre un c'est un défenseur
convenable puis c'est quelqu'un qui peut
assez vite se projeter en nba je pense
après derrière à voir mais c'est c'est
ce qui me permet surimpose 2,3 ça me
parait ça me paraît correct parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de prise de risque et on est
sûr d'une risque calculé et récompense à
la hauteur du risque je pense et on sait
vers combat
écoute samba - poste 2-3 toute façon je
vous dis partout où tu as quoi tu as
garé un risque on ne sait même pas s'il
va rester fatah je bois je suis preneur
du plus fort mais que sur un poste de
3,20 john green s'est vendu qui jouait
déjà en d-league cette année qui a
réussi à scorer à scorer déjà alors
qu'il avait 18 points de moyenne d'âge
et des granules chez quand même c'est
quoi un match correct à chantage ça peut
être pas mal du côté d'orlando ont pas
tous au choix si son orlando n'y
reviendra pour le choix 8 et le choix si
ce qui sera le premier d'une beaucoup
jouent pas pour puisque oklahoma à je ne
sais plus un certain pourcentage de
cette draft et donc ils n'ont pas eu de
chance à la loterie
il se retrouve à être le choix numéro 6
rémy alors là est ce qu'on continue à
empiler les talents et puis on jette
tout dans une marmite noir mais ça c'est
une bonne question c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas de pas de chance pour le coup de se
retrouver impliqué en 6 après un pic à 2
ou 3 cette année ou qu'ici c'était on va
pas se mentir c'est un centre de
formation c'était désespoir qui joue et
c'est intéressant le groupe il est
intéressant mais c'est tellement jeune
en fait un leader qui est clair est
claire c'est celle d'alexander là dedans
qui est le joueur d'avenir de cette
franchise autour duquel tu construis
mais tata plein de mecs qui sont en
train décore ta le p'tit loup dorthe que
moi j'adore ta beaucoup ces ch'tis qui a
monté des trucs tateo maledon qui a été
bon cette année les basly je regarde si
camoes brown c'est pas mal
et en parlant fort c'est dans votre jeu
mais j'appartiens philip alston j'ai pu
enfin bon il avait fait éclore des mecs
l'aï surpris kemba walker qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de kemba walker
moi je sais pas est ce que ce qu'ils
vont faire une crise paul kemba walker
ou est-ce que ce qui compte aussi contre
le traité immédiatement j'en sais rien
donc faut voir
écoute c'est une équipe qui manque
tellement de choses que moi je le
resterai à nouveau talent parce que j'ai
du mal à voir autre chose dans ta
construction tu draft aux talents si
possible un mec qui a un petit âtre et
si tu veux t'en servir pour le scoring
parce qu'en dehors de gi joe alexander
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de corinne dans
cette équipe a le plus gros talents
disponibles le poste vraiment j'ai
l'impression qu'on pourra le faire
fuiter un peu n'importe où dans ce cas
là on est on est sûr book naito cumbia à
mon sens un cool il ya plus pour le côté
boyals côté hype et le fait qu'il était
déjà en d-league cette année puis il ya
un vrai potentiel alors c'est pas tout à
fait finalisé il ya encore un tir à 3
qui est en chantier c'est même au delà
du champ tient ce qu'on a faim de 100%
sur la saison si l'on a book like un peu
d'espèces d'agents stories du scoring
qui peut mettre des gros tirs les choix
sont un peu compliquées c'est pas
forcément assez dans le cas de sean
plaît mais dans l'est dans les deux cas
alors c'est des profils très différents
mais dans les deux cas on est sur des
joueurs qui peuvent apporter des points
comme un gadget a une dimension physique
qui le rend un peu plus un peu plus
intrigante style à 2,3 de mons envergure
boktai c'est un petit peu plus petits
tout dépend si on veut vraiment partir
sur insultent et choquent pas si on veut
partir sur un 2 capable de scorer ou sur
du 3 4 qui vont qui pour moi finira
forcément cadre de toute façon avec
peut-être des questions sur les genoux
on est un petit peu entre les deux pour
moi la ccc c'est pas forcément pour pas
forcément ça me de se décider sur un sur
deux sur ceux sur ce profil là on
élimine scotty barnes ce que tu barnes
je vais me tromper en disant ça mais
scotty barnes il a émis hier et dit je
vois pas un upside de fou mais je le
vois dans une équipe qui aura besoin de
quelqu un projectile qui a forcé moins
de talent mais qu'à un bunker plutôt
quelqu'un qui soit prêt à jouer tout de
suite et qui soit capable d'apporter des
choses différentes là si on est si on
est sur du c'ur du comment dire sur du
c'ur du potentiel sur du talent sur du
scoring
moi j'aime beaucoup barnes mais c'est
plus un joueur d'impact physique et un
joueur de deux volumes à l'heure
actuelle que 15 joueurs capables
d'apporter sur le scoring alors émis
beaucoup mines galles sur les postes 3 4
go james goodnight sûr
si tu me proposes âgées plus tendance à
aller chercher un poste 3-4 même si on a
déjà dû pousser ce qui là dessous je
pense que comme un gars pourrait me
convenir de ce que je viens de romain la
pourpre au gros gros défenseur aussi
potentiellement mais il était déjà très
bon défendu mes recettes
donc ok ici choix numéro 7 golden state
warriors qui récupère le choix des
petites banques mais bob myers rémy
quelle belle position et qui va tu va
nous dire ce dont tu as besoin il ya
déjà des rumeurs de trade sur sur ce kit
pour améliorer le roadster immédiatement
est ce que ce serait une belle option
quoi ah oui oui là il y a des vrais
choix qui sont qui vont se poser enfin
des questions qui vont se poser cet
été-là poids dans les jours qui viennent
pour bob myers et des variances série
golden state c'est une franchise un peu
ses franchises noble qui qui bossent
bien qui travaille dur depuis depuis des
années maintenant et qui a eu du succès
mais c'est une équipe qui
traditionnellement à bosser sur le moyen
voire long terme qui a bossé
intelligemment
j'ai l'impression pour la première fois
depuis longtemps ils sont peut-être un
besoin d'urgence du fait du
vieillissement de ses stars en fait on
est écoeuré que les thompson je vais
faire mal et du monde en disant ça mais
je dis pas les 2 et la fenêtre de tir
pour essayer de retourner chercher un
titre avec ces deux là elle se réduit tu
vois donc le trade j'y crois fort j'y
crois fort fort fort ça parle de james
wyman beaucoup pour monter je serais pas
surprise si andrew higgins sortait aussi
dans le temps les rumeurs dans les jours
qui viennent
donc pourquoi pas monter dans la draft
pour aller chercher quelqu'un si c'est
pas le cas parce que bon pour l'instant
ce n'est pas prévu donc si c'est pas le
cas
j'ai l'impression qu'avec ces deux pays
qu'ils ont pas ce qu'ils vont piquer en
14 aussi donc c'est pas mal il faudrait
aller chercher quelqu'un d'aussi nba
reddick possible parce que pour la
première fois depuis longtemps ils ont
besoin d'un mec qui va les aider dès
cette année pour devenir à contender
alors
pardon dans quels secteurs du jeu et si
on a quelqu'un de dispo sur les postes
arrières qui soit nba ready je prends
parce que steve que rake et thomson on
voit bien avec les blessures qui sont
accumulés avec tout ça c'est plus enfin
si je peux éviter de les faire jouer 82
matchs à 34 minutes par match j'en serai
content comment donc
heitz
fait sens bon même si même s'ils vont
tout faire exploser si foncier trade up
derrière lions soit fait avant ça
restera la science fiction mais naïve
dans ce cas là par rapport à ce que tu
dis ça fait sens parce que c'est un
joueur qui est ok cc du scoreur de uconn
alors y'a peut-être pas forcément un
plafond très très élevé l'une polyvalent
dans ce corps est une tâche moins sont
pas tus que tu me dis là c'est bien un
mec qui soit qu'il soit on n'a pas
besoin je pense que là les warriors du
nouveau cd de curry ils ont juste besoin
d'un mec qui peut venir en rotation
juste avant de sécurité thompson et
apporter ses 15000 18 minutes dès l'an
prochain quoi dans ce cas là dans ce cas
là je pense que book nights et c'est
sûrement peut-être tu auras moins tu
auras moins de temps d'adaptation que
sur certains profils peut-être plus
talentueux mais moins - près à l'heure
actuelle donc dubaï s'est fait ça ça a
du sens à ce niveau là le yukon à golden
state ont pour pour james book night
donc sophomore des complices de
connecticut
on va finir avec le choix demi on
retourne à orlando
rémy tu disais tout à l'heure là tu es
dans la même optique avec le choix 5 et
qui on envoie quoi alors ouais c'est
parce que je t'avoue j'ai pas tous dotés
désolé je suis un très mauvais gm
on a pris quelques piques 5 du coup d'y
aller n'gongue de pics inquiet ce qui
est d'ailleurs un bon pique je pense ont
cinq écoutes faut voir un petit peu ce
qui est encore de dispo en termes de
talent là si on prenait les trois quatre
plus gros talent en restant sur le
bordereau moi tu proposes quoi comme le
profil
maintenant je ferai je ferai
je
coty barnes sur ce coup là justement
parce que pas forcément un talent fou
mes joueurs avec du volume physique
il ya peut-être un peu de manque aux six
dans le secteur intérieur du côté du
côté d'orlando sur quelqu'un qui se font
un peu un peu dans la dureté un peu un
peu brut de décoffrage comme on sait le
faire à florida state ces dernières
années puisqu'ils ont sorti quelques
mecs sur ces profils là et barnes barn
sur barnes en soit 8 ça me paraît pas
des collants la danse vite dans 2,18
d'envergure sur le poste 4
bon j'ai dit à un pourcentage aux
lancers francs qui est pas génial une
main gauche a développé par contre il ya
un vrai sens de la passe donc il était
quasiment à dakhla de passes de moyenne
cette année donc il peut être aussi
facilitateur dans la construction du jeu
ça peut être ça peut être intéressant
d'une équipe qui qui se reconstruit
qu'il cherche pas à savoir un mec dg
efficace dans l'impact dans ces choses
là
est ce que c'est ce que c'est pas
intéressant en plus ce côté régional de
l'étape peut aider derrière donc moi ça
me paraît ça me parait ça me paraît pas
mal ça marche toujours
et puis je regardais un peu le roster de
orlando la saison prochaine post 4 ça
peut être intéressant parce que le 5 il
est il assez remplie on a toujours
moments bas qui est là il ya wendell
carter qui arrivait de chicago la dent
les trade qui est qui et plus au fur et
à mesure de sa carrière qui devient plus
15.4 j'ai l'impression remplir ce poste
4 pourrait m'intéresser
après après la solution il ay ay jackson
mais c'est un peu plus bas derrière les
jackson mais après on est plus sur dur
dur dur du 5,4 que fraises sur les cinq
cas du 4-5 c'est un peu il ay ay ay ay
jackson tu ta ta ta tu serais de choque
pas du tout c'est beaucoup beaucoup
moins passeur donc encore une fois après
tout dépend de qui va coacher sont aussi
rentables orientations de jeu l'a mené
sur un poste 4 efficace physiquement
mais qui passe sa valve jackson s'est
totalement dit shah et sahil ya quand
même de l'ops hyde si le shoot arrive un
jour à se développer chez barnes si on
sait qu orlando est pas la meilleure
franchise pour développeurs de ses
prospects sait pas faire injure pour
prévenir sa part sur scotty barnes on y
allait de tous côtés ok eh bien on va
récapituler khenin gamme irait donc à à
detroit evans mot blé à houston giles à
cleveland
sharif cooper à toronto à orlando
john green ou donc scotty barnes avec le
8 à oklahoma
on envoyait qing ming à la roma et james
goodnight à golden state voilà le top 8
le split de deûle de la paire reverchon
le roi des décideurs actuels qui font
beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup de
décisions à prendre à part pour le
premier choix qui est un peu attendu
sinon derrière il ya quand même pas mal
de suspense donc on va s'amuser soir de
la draft merci beaucoup et demi avec
plaisir les gars c'est en tout ce que
vous nous sortez un une race 1.0 là on a
le big board déjà donc une autre
placement à nous sans répondre les
équipes et la mode draft devrait arriver
à devrait arriver sous dizaine barre
c'est parfait parfait on veut sera là
dessus pour premier merci romain gary et
puis habiter un taux tout le monde
évidemment vous renvoie si vous voulez
connaître tous les noms on a prononcé
dans cette vidéo
vers le site envergure point ces eaux il
ya près 60 scouting report
à l'heure où je parle il y en aura
peut-être encore plus à l'avenir donc
blindés même pour les prospects du
deuxième tour vous devriez être armés
merci à tous à bientôt et on se retrouve
envergure penser aux et en podcast shao